Robert asks why do you release the  askgaryvee show in the evening are you  trying to target to East Coast commuters  Robert great question I appreciate you  having the respect in me to think I have  that much strategy I do like to say  everything I do is on purpose this one  though on the other hand happens to  completely beyond the heads of Zack not  usually Zack actually there's actually a  very little to do with it yeah it has a  whole lot to do with d Rock who's on the  other side of this and has to do  everything with my schedule here we are  at nine thirty or 940 taping today's  episode yesterday when do we take the  iraq well 1 p.m. yesterday obviously  that came out later it's 948 I expect  the Arak specially with only one video  question today to bang the soundness  should be up by two or three or one and  will be out soon so completely  predicated on the insanity that is my  schedule